[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal
ende eines spektakels das olympische
feuer ist erloschen
die winterspiele von peking zeigen sich
noch einmal sorgfältig orchestriert und
kontrolliert das nächste mal wird an das
dann leuchten die olympischen ringe bei
den sommerspielen paris guten abend ioc
präsident bach sprach in seiner
abschlussrede von wahrhaft
außergewöhnlichen spielen ja das kann
man wohl so sagen die athleten
hermetisch abgeschottet teils im hardter
isolation normale zuschauer fehlten
politische gäste aus dem westlichen
ausland auch einige regierungen
boykottierten die spiele ja ausdrücklich
andere wie die deutsche formulierten das
nicht so deutlich hielten sich aber
ebenfalls fern die viel beschworene
völkerverständigung fand jedenfalls
nicht statt für die athleten waren das
traurige rahmenbedingungen sie hätten es
anders verdient gehabt zur sportlichen
seite kommen wir am ende der sendung
noch ausführlicher die politische und
sportpolitische bilanz zieht jetzt
christian hoffmann
der chinesische knoten gilt als symbol
des glücks und soll die verbundenheit
chinas mit der welt zeigen so wollen die
organisatoren ihre winterspiele sehen
doch es gab mehr trennendes als einen
dass es gab eine drinnen und draußen der
spiele drinnen in drei zonen waren die
olympia-teilnehmer abgeschottet wurden
ständig kontrolliert getestet
desinfiziert das system hat funktioniert
eine infektionswelle blieb aus 440
teilnehmer wurden positiv getestet und
mussten in solche separate unterkünfte
wie kombinierer eric frenzel
zehn tage saß er fast
das umfeld war sehr schwierig pandemie
bedingt aber natürlich auch die
besondere situation in china insgesamt
als corona sicher lobte ioc präsident
bach die winterspiele mit handverlesenen
zuschauern und ohne sich wirklich frei
bewegen zu können ging das aber auf
kosten der olympischen stimmung
[Musik]
mit diesen wirklich außergewöhnlichen
olympischen winterspielen in peking
begrüßen wir china als ein wintersport
land
eine verbeugung vor china mit dem
verweis auf politische neutralität nimmt
das olympische komitee die katastrophale
menschenrechtslage in china kritiklos
hin auch die olympia teilnehmer sollten
sich nicht kritisch äußern
draußen außerhalb der olympischen zone
verfolgten die chinesen die spiele vor
allem über die staatsmedien
eine propagandashow perfekt inszeniert
mit gigantischen sportstätten und
angeblich im ganzen land wintersport
treiben den chinesen zaungäste waren sie
auch bei der abschlussfeier
dennoch sind diese pekinger stolz auf
ihre spiele
dass wir unter solchen umständen in der
lage waren die spiele zu organisieren
zeigt wie stark wir als nation sind
ich würde nicht sagen dass wir schon
eine große wintersport nation sind aber
china hat einen großen schritt in
richtung gemacht es waren wohl die
umstrittensten und meist kontrollierten
winterspiele in vier jahren laden
mailand und cortina in italien zu den 25
olympischen winterspielen ein zu hoffen
jenseits von corona und ohne dunkle
schatten einer diktatur
unser china korrespondent ulf röller hat
dieser spiele in peking beobachtet
darüber wollen wir reden was würdest du
sagen waren diese spiele aus
chinesischer sicht einen erfolg
ich glaube aus chinesischer sicht und
für den chinesischen präsidenten ski
waren sie ein erfolg es hat seine
position im land noch mal weiter
gestärkt auch wenn das schwierig es war
ein sehr starker führer dieses landes
ist es war vor allem wichtig für das
land dass es kein corona ausbruch
gegeben hat darauf ist man stolz das
kontrollsystem hat funktioniert die
sportstätten waren sehr sehr gut
technisch auf dem neuesten stand damit
hat sich china wettbewerbsfähig
präsentiert und das land war sehr sehr
stabil es gab keine politischen unruhen
oder demonstration weder in hongkong
noch in gent damit hat keiner wirklich
gerechnet weil es eben diese harte hand
gibt aber china konnte zeigen dass ein
stabiles land ist das problem ist eben
die schattenseite dieser spieler und wer
genau hingucken wollte und das haben
viele in der welt haben eben auch die
hässliche fratze chinas gesehen und das
ist dass china immer mehr eine brutale
diktatur wird das kaum westliche
ehrengäste da waren um sich die spiele
anzusehen war dass peking egal
ich glaube egal war es peking nicht
deswegen hat man im vorfeld vor den
spielen massiv druck in europa aufgebaut
dass es keine einheitliche entscheidung
in europa gab zu einem diplomatischen
boykott dass europa also nicht amerika
zusammen einen diplomatischen boykott
genannt hat sondern es gab vereinzelt
denn da die das getan haben es ist ein
erfolg für china gewesen aber mehr war
eben nicht drin und china hat sich sehr
bemüht quasi zu zeigen dass es stark ist
es gibt aber und das ist das besondere
an diesen spielen eben diese teilung der
welt ist sehr sehr deutlich geworden die
autokraten sind gekommen und der
wichtigste wohl putin war am ersten tag
der spiele da und hat deutlich gemacht
dass diese achse peking moskau eben sehr
sehr stark ist und sehr wichtig ist und
das macht den besten sehr große sorgen
wobei der webseite einen interessanten
auftritt von chinesischen außenminister
jetzt bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz der einerseits die
nato ganz im sinne russlands kritisierte
aber andererseits auch sagte der
grundsatz der souveränität und
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen geld auch
für die ukraine
was war das eine art warnschuss richtung
moskau
ich glaube schon ein bisschen china hat
lange beziehungen zu der ukraine das ist
auch ein land wo man viel geld
investiert hat aber was noch wichtiger
ist es gibt durchaus befürchtungen china
dass putin quasi ein flächenbrand in
europa auslöst dass es ein krieg in
europa gibt und der daneben auch die
europäischen wirtschaften sehr stark in
mitleidenschaft ziehen würden und das
wäre wiederum ganz ganz schwierig weil
europa eben dieser unglaublich wichtige
handelspartner für china ist in china
selber läuft die wirtschaft zurzeit
nicht gut wegen der pandemie und land
braucht den europäischen markt und wenn
der verloren geht da muss man eindeutig
sagen dass dann eben auch diese
chinesisch versprechen von glück und von
mehr reichtum nicht mehr so leicht
durchzuführen zu durchzusetzen ist aber
es gilt auch für die chinesen dass wenn
putin es schafft weiter unruhe in der
region zu schaffen und amerika europa
damit zu beschäftigen dass es durchaus
den chinesen recht also sie erwarten
eigentlich von putin dass er hier in
dieser beziehung das florett und nicht
dem vorschlaghammer benutzt ob er da der
richtige mann ist das wird man sehen
dankeschön für diese analysen danke nach
peking
im konflikt mit russland gibt es heute
unterschiedliche signale einerseits gab
es ein telefongespräch zwischen putin
und frankreichs präsident makro putin
soll zugestimmt haben sich gemeinsam um
eine waffenruhe in der ost ukraine zu
bemühen dort gibt es entlang der von
russischen separatisten kontrollierten
gebiete heftige gefechte auf der anderen
seite setzen russland und belarus ihr
gemeinsames militärmanöver fort
ursprünglich hätte das heute beendet
werden sollen aber daran hatte wohl
sowieso schon keiner mehr geglaubt bela
rust das jahrzehntelang auf einen
gewissen abstand zu moskau und
eigenständigkeit bedacht war ist nun
also auch noch aufmarschplatz für
russische truppen in der ukraine wird
auch das sorgfältig wahrgenommen axel
sturm und christian senn beginn ihren
berichten
genau acht jahre ist es jetzt her als
über 100 menschen hier am marienplatz in
kiew ihr leben verloren die meisten von
ihnen gezielt erschossen von
scharfschützen heute erinnern
ukrainerinnen ukraine wieder an die
opfer der revolution die als himmlische
hundertschaft im kollektiven gedächtnis
weiterleben
den frieden den wir heute haben den
haben wir diesen menschen zu verdanken
den menschen die hier vor acht jahren
ermordet wurden
auf den mai dann folgte 2014 die
annexion der krim durch russland und der
krieg mit den pro russischen
separatisten in der ost ukraine
der krieg dauert an ist wieder
aufgeflammt und auch hier rätseln sie an
diesem gedenktag wieweit putin jetzt
gehen wird
ich glaube nicht dass putin so dumm ist
kiew anzugreifen mit bomben und raketen
auf friedliche zivilisten zu schießen
vielleicht auf irgendwelche ziele mit
strategischer bedeutung vielleicht
breitet sich der konflikt im donbass aus
sie können uns doch einfach provozieren
sagt tatjana
aber nein in kiew anzugreifen muss man
wirklich ein vollidiot sein
entschuldigen sie meine worte aber das
wäre einfach dumm
panzer rollen über das feld kampfjet
donnern heute sollte das russisch bilder
russische militärmanöver in belarus
enden russlands militär sollte wieder
abziehen aber putin hat es sich anders
überlegt wegen der bedrohung an den
grenzen und der angespannten lage im
donbass wie es heißt
die entscheidung unserer
staatsoberhäupter besteht darin die
übung der reaktionsfähigkeit des
unionsstaates fortzusetzen die general
stäbe der republik belarus und der
russischen föderation werden weitere
schritte ausarbeiten und wir werden
diese entscheidungen mit leben füllen
zur gleichen zeit in der ost ukraine
beschießen und beschuldigen sich die
ukrainische armee und die prorussischen
separatisten gegenseitig tausende
verletzungen der waffenruhe allein
gestern
europa weiter in sorge vor einem krieg -
sagen wir unsere truppe ist um ein
vielfaches stärker geworden und die
moral ist ungebrochen wir sind jederzeit
bereit unsere aufgaben zu erfüllen
russland fordert die ukraine müsse
direkt mit den separatisten verhandeln
um fortschritte im friedensprozess zu
erreichen das lehnen sie auch hier am
mai dann in kiew strikt ab wir sollten
auf keinen fall mit den separatisten
reden das sind illegale bewaffnete
erzählen sie uns mit wem man reden muss
scheint klar der konflikt kommt aus
russland sagen sie und dort werden die
entscheidungen getroffen
die politikwissenschaftlerin sabine
fischer von der stiftung wissenschaft
und politik die auch die bundesregierung
berät ist uns zugeschaltet sie ist
expertin für russland und osteuropa und
insbesondere hat sie als
forschungsschwerpunkt russische außen
und sicherheitspolitik guten abend herr
fischer hallo frischling sie waren
gerade eine woche in moskau sind heute
erst aus moskau zurück gekommen was für
ein druck da haben sie mitgebracht wie
wird in der russischen öffentlichkeit
über diesen konflikt gesprochen oder
berichtet
es wird natürlich berichtet bislang
würde ich sagen oder einschränken bis
vor bis vor zwei tagen
war die situation im donbass noch nicht
so dominant dass es gab natürlich
medienberichte zeitungsberichte et
cetera habe zum beispiel die olympischen
spiele waren in den
hauptnachrichtensendungen am abend
eindeutig wichtiger immer am anfang wenn
man sich umfragen anschaut dann sieht
man das in der russischen bevölkerung
sehr wohl eine befürchtung besteht also
angst vor krieg besteht allerdings das
bild von von krieg dass aus dieser angst
erkennbar wird ist ein etwas anderes als
das was wir wahrnehmen denn in der
russischen bevölkerung
hat man vor allen dingen angst vor einem
groß krieg gegen die nato gegen die usa
und das ist ja nicht das was wir von
hier aus sehen wie man sie dass das
nicht das was wir von hier aus sehen wir
sehen vor allen dingen einen konflikt
zwischen russland und der ukraine
ja und bei uns wird vor allen dingen
diskutiert was passiert wenn russland
jetzt die ukraine angreifen sollte in
russland sehen die menschen den konflikt
zwischen russland und den usa und der
nato und das entspricht tatsächlich sehr
stark auch dem narrativ das zum beispiel
in den staatlich kontrollierten medien
verbreitet wird die ukraine wird gar
nicht so sehr als kriegsgegner
wahrgenommen sondern viel stärke
wirklich als naja wenn man so sagen will
marionette der usa als manipulierte
manipulierte staat
über den die usa eben gegen die gegen
gegen russland und gegen russische
interessen vorgehen als die krim
annektiert wurde kam das ja in der
russischen bevölkerung mehrheitlich sehr
gut an also auch putins umfragewerte
wieder etwas im keller waren schossen
nach oben wie sieht das denn aus
russische bild auf die ukraine aus wird
das als ein land wahrgenommen das
eigentlich zu russland gehört oder was
für eine grundhaltung herrschte vor es
ist tatsächlich so dass 2014/15 die
annexion der krim innenpolitisch
unglaublich gut verwertet werden konnte
das hat er wirklich putins ratings bis
fast 100 prozent hochgetrieben
davon könnte man jetzt bei einem
größeren krieg gegen also beim einmarsch
in die ost ukraine oder sogar darüber
hinaus einem größeren krieg gegen die
ukraine mit sicherheit nicht ausgehen
das hat man im grunde genommen schon
2014 15 auch gesehen bei den
kriegshandlungen im donbass die in der
russischen bevölkerung wesentlich
weniger unterstützung genossen haben als
eben die annexion der krim ja also die
vorstellung
dass eine überwiegende mehrheit der
russischen bevölkerung glaubt die
ukraine gehöre eigentlich zu russland
und einen solchen facebook unterstützen
würde die ist sicherlich falsch und
darin liegt auch tatsächlich eine große
herausforderung für präsident putin für
die russische politische führung denn in
dem moment wo tatsächlich ist zu einem
größeren krieg käme und auch die
verluste für die russische bevölkerung
spürbar würden zum beispiel in gestalt
von gefallenen soldaten zum beispiel
auch in gestalt von wirklich ernsthaften
wirtschaftlichen folgen etc dann müsste
man davon ausgehen dass das die
unterstützung auch für den präsidenten
eben sehr stark nachlassen würde aber es
wäre ja auch denkbar dass es eine
kleinere begrenzte invasion als die sich
dann ja auch ganz anders von der
propaganda her darstellen lässt
sicherlich also auch in moskau ich meine
ich habe jetzt in der letzten woche
natürlich vor allen dingen auch mit
außenpolitik experten expertinnen
gesprochen also mit den leuten mit denen
ich eben auch normalerweise zu tun habe
und da werden wie auch hier alle
möglichen szenarien diskutiert ja und
ein begrenzter einmarsch und eine dann
tatsächlich auch selbst anerkannte
besetzungen des donners vielleicht ein
bisschen über die territorien die jetzt
umstritten sind hinausgehend
werden wird diskutiert es wird auch eine
stärkere hybride kriegsführung gegen die
gegen die ukraine diskutiert als
möglichkeit ja aber man muss eben dazu
sagen dass auch die leute mit denen ich
jetzt gesprochen habe in den letzten
tagen
vom entscheidungs zentrum eben einfach
relativ weit entfernt sind gerne also
diese entscheidung wird sehr ist einfach
sehr sehr ja die wird im grunde genommen
von einem menschen getroffen ist das
vorziehen und insofern stochern eben
auch doch hat die russische experten
community da auch sehr stark im nebel
mit hybrider tricks führung den begriff
kann vielleicht nicht jeder sofort
einordnen damit sind eben die
informationskampagnen zb der
cyberangriffe gemeint also die
stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
die eben dazu führen können dass der
ukrainische staat immer weiter sozusagen
unterminiert wird und ja genau also da
da könnten auch terroranschläge dazu
zählen aber eben auch tatsächlich
begrenzter einmarsch der natürlich auch
enorme die stabilisierungs wirkung hat
oder was wir jetzt sehen in belarus oder
auch im schwarzen meer die
militärübungen heute ist ja die
belarussische russische militärübung an
der nordgrenze der ukraine verlängert
worden ja ohne dass tatsächlich ein
enddatum bekannt gegeben worden ist das
sind alles maßnahmen die für die ukraine
natürlich extrem die stabilisierend
wirken frau fischer danken für diese
einschätzungen vielen dank ihnen
das gespräch haben wir aufgezeichnet und
mit dem thema russland und ukraine wie
das jetzt auch eine nachricht erst
nochmal weiterhin
spd-fraktionschef mützenich hat sich für
weiteres diplomatisches engagement
ausgesprochen es sei wichtig dass jede
minute genutzt werde damit es nicht zu
einem krieg kommen sagte mützenich der
zdf sendung berlin direkt er erhoffe
sich von weiteren gesprächen dass es
doch noch zu verabredungen komme die
nato und die amerikanische seite hätten
ja auch vorschläge unterbreitet zur
corona situation die zahlen vom
robert-koch-institut zeigen erneut eine
etwas niedrigere sieben tage incidents
und im wochenvergleich weniger
neuinfektionen die gesundheitsämter
meldeten dem rk ii
118000 32 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind
7128 weniger als vor einer woche
73 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages hinzu die sieben tage incidents
liegt jetzt bei 1300
46,3
die britische königin elizabeth die
zweite ist positiv auf das corona virus
getestet worden der buckingham palast
teilte mit die 95 jährige habe leichte
symptome
auf der brennenden auto fähre vor der
mittelmeerinsel korfu ist ein weiterer
überlebender gefunden worden mehr als 48
stunden hatte der 21 jährige lkw fahrer
aus belarus an bord aus gehört er blieb
unverletzt
rettungskräfte entdeckten jedoch auch
ein erstes todesopfer
zehn menschen werden noch vermisst der
brand ist noch immer nicht vollständig
gelöscht warum ausbrach ist unklar
in der champion hat die stromproduktion
am sogenannten großen renaissance
staudamm am nebe gonnen regierungschef
ahmed eröffnete die 145 meter hohe
talsperre die nach ihrer fertigstellung
die größte afrikas werden sollen
äthiopien bis rund 60 prozent der
bevölkerung mit strom versorgen die
anlage ist jedoch umstritten vor allem
ägypten und der sultan fürchten um ihre
wasserversorgung durch den nil
zur fußball-bundesliga mit vielen toren
heute es gab drei spiele mit diesen
ergebnissen hertha bsc rb leipzig 1 zu 6
dortmund gladbach sechs zu null und
bayern münchen greuther fürth 4 zu 1
dass ein sturmtief ist gerade weg da
kommt schon das nächste es gibt aktuelle
unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor gebietsweise schweren
sturm bis orkanstärke
in verbindung mit schauern und einzelnen
gewittern und zwar für niedersachsen
nordrhein westfalen hessen rheinland
pfalz saarland thüringen sachsen
baden-württemberg bayern und mecklenburg
vorpommern
und jetzt die wetteraussichten für
morgen sehr wechselhaft mit etwas sonne
und vielen kräftigen schauern sowie
einzelnen gewittern oberhalb von etwa
500 metern auch schnee
stürmischer südwestwind in der nacht
vorübergehend mit einzelnen orkanböen
tagsüber noch einzelne schwere sturmböen
fünf bis zehn grad die weiteren
aussichten allmählich wetterberuhigung
und wieder häufiger sonne dienstag vier
bis elf am donnerstag 7 bis 15 grad
und jetzt noch wie immer sonntags der
ausblick auf die nächste woche so weit
man in diesen bewegten zeiten blicken
kann einige wichtige ereignisse die
schon feststehen hat jörg welt
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
die eu außenminister werden morgen in
brüssel neben dem russland ukraine
konflikt auch über die lage in mali
beraten nach dem abzug frankreichs aus
dem westafrikanischen krisenstaat steht
die eu mission dort auf dem prüfstand ab
morgen wird ein fünfter impfstoff auf
den deutschen markt kommen das präparat
von nowaks könnte vor allem im skeptiker
zum umdenken bewegen die vorbehalte
gegen die neuartigen m rna und vector
impfstoffe haben
die mercedes benz group wird am
donnerstag ihre jahreszahlen vorlegen
obwohl die lage am automarkt derzeit
angespannt ist wird eine positive bilanz
erwartet der stuttgarter konzern hatte
sich zuletzt neu aufgestellt und die
auto und lkw sparte von einander
getrennt
ob karneval fastnacht oder fasching ab
donnerstag werden wieder die narren los
sein wegen der pandemie wird allerdings
mit angezogener handbremse gefeiert so
fallen an den tollen tagen viele
veranstaltungen aus oder finden nur im
kleinen rahmen statt
das war es von uns morgen abend freuen
sich hier christian sievers sind hanna
zimmermann ob sie oder nur 30 gibt es
die nächste heute express in eine gute
woche nach wieder sehend wiedersehen
[Musik]